Is there an advantage to using a cold pack or hot pack on a tuber mass?
Thinking about hot and cold therapy
Yes, there can be so well partly it depends on where the tuber mass is if the tuber is in your colon
You know or in your intestinal tract
Use that the heat is not going to go deep enough the cold is not going to go deep enough
So remember a pack or cold pack is probably only going to penetrate
You know maybe a centimeter
So if your mass is close to the surface
absolutely and
So then you go, okay, what should I use heat or cold?
There can be benefit to using to alternating like put hot on for five minutes
Then cold on for five minutes and hot on for five minutes. You can get a
Beneficial
Pumpied action of the limp around the tumor. You could get a
the benefit of cryotherapy ice therapy or
hyperthermia
So there could be benefits to that too because both
Cryotherapy cold therapy can kill a cancer can kill the cells in a tumor and so can heat
So what should I do?
Well do both, you know, so you could do that pumpied action five minutes on five minutes off or you could do I'm going to do heat today and cold tomorrow
Play with those and see if you get a response
There's nothing wrong with doing that is if the tumor is close to the surface again if the tumor is pretty deep
The chance of you affecting the tumor is pretty slim
You know if you have it close to the surface then you have the ability to do some of those things yes